hi-yah so I'm a teacher and in my
teaching I like to use stories and
metaphors a lot because they make
complicated topics easier to grasp one
topic that I find that my students have
a hard time with is asynchronous
programming so I tell a story about
asynchronous programming normally I tell
this in the course of a lesson which is
50 minutes but you guys are all very
smart in advance so you know about it so
I'm going to tell it in 4 minutes
so this is H n H n is often very hungry
which he says here so he goes the
Parisians will know this is called quick
burgers H n likes to go to slow burgers
where the delivery times of hamburgers
can go up to 500 milliseconds which is
incredibly long so let's see what
happens the first version of what I'm
going to show is synchronous so this
time everything that happens is
synchronous and people have to wait for
each other so let's see what happens
nice music H n goes in your hamburger oh
by the way I got to show this I think I
made the world the world's first can I
use the mouse yeah
first the responsive hamburger
restaurant look at this look at the
tables
it's anyone from Guinness here now
probably oh I got it four minutes all
right so he's ordering he's ordering and
as he's ordering Marie the waitress is
going to go to the chef and she's going
to order but look at HN I can show this
he's standing still because it's
synchronous he cannot move look he's
standing still and what happens next is
another customer comes in
while the hamburgers being prepared and
he's also standing still this is
Philippe Philip by the way and he said
Michelle and yes to wait so he's getting
angry and he can move and even worse hñ
needs go to the bathroom
but he can't move either so it's a
pretty bad situation in a synchronous
environment so thanks to chef he gets
he's never grow up next scenario the
chef thinks what can I do I'm gonna make
it in parallel I'm gonna make the
hamburger while he's waiting so how will
a chain know that his hamburger is done
the chef thinks you know what I'm gonna
ask for his phone number and when it's
time I'm gonna call him back you know so
if I already stole a liver joke by the
way but I'm trying it again I'm gonna
call him back when the burger is done so
let's see he's hungry orders from muddy
mud he says yes what's your phone number
i chen is all like oh my god you want my
phone number he's blushing because he's
like why do you want my phone number I
think it's like yes I can call you when
the hamburgers done and he's like okay
whatever somebody goes to the chef
George the Burger Chef goes what's your
phone number but he goes oh my god my
phone number why do you want my phone
about apparently you forgot about this
which is really weird anyway so she
gives his phone number and he says okay
it's fine he goes prepare yeah wait a
while he's gonna wait over here
hamburgers done he's gonna call hello
hello who says yes chef hamburgers done
okay
yeah I'm gonna get the hamburger okay
yeah it's fine
or is it because of what was Marie doing
in that story she didn't have anything
to do she just gave the hamburger oh
like she passed it on why was she in
this callback hell you know come back
how so the chef thing is what can I do
I'm gonna do it differently I'm gonna
give something to my customers and I'm
gonna say it's like one of those pages
you know have you seen it in the round
things that light up I'm gonna give them
the pages I'm gonna say it's not done
yet
but when it's done and I promise it'll
be done then it will light up so let's
see what happens to yours but I think
yeah here's a pager here's a page which
is wait wait wait wait wait now when the
hammer is done the pager will light up
and poof it turns into a hammer it's a
magic pager we gotta play with it it's a
little yeah
it's okay anyway so all's good all's
good all's good but you might think you
know there's another solution to this
because Marie could have also given a
chance number directly to the chef
why did she give her own number so let's
imagine that she did this she gave not
her number but a chance number to the
chef it's the same night a chance
sending outside it gets a call who is
this it's a chef hello
you want to go on a date Marie and then
Jen's like no I'm not married I'm a chen
she gave you money she gave you my
number because oh okay do you want to go
on a date then and the Chan says yes
chef comes out and they live happily
ever after the end
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you